what did you learn making the halloween
movies thus far
that you think you'll take with you to
when you do exorcist
wow um very different subgenres of
horror
and i don't i haven't thought about it
in that capacity i'm literally it to me
it's as different as making
stronger and pineapple express they're
just so um
unbelievably different one is
very um
primal
and the other is very academic and so
it's just trying to
switch gears there i'm sure i'll have it
just i'll know more a year from now when
i've
gotten
a handle on on what exorcist is
um the script's written and it's a very
entirely different writing process so i
i don't i don't have a good answer for
you on that one yet
um well i know that with exorcist you
guys are planning on making a trilogy
and i'm curious knowing going in knowing
you are gonna make a trilogy just to
confirm you're doing all three films
that's the idea right now yeah
so when you are in the scripting process
how much were you because maybe you're
treating us a little differently than
halloween in terms of when you're
writing the script for the first one i'm
assuming you you have an idea of where
you want to ultimately be going
yes yeah i mean the first one of our
trilogy is written in the second two are
being outlined so we're we got a ways to
go on that but um but we know where
we're going it's a you know it's a
new journey and um
some familiar characters and some new
ones as well
um my last thing for you because i
really have to wrap uh who's writing the
the script if you don't mind maybe
yeah it's uh me and a co-writer named
peter sattler
cool
we did a movie or we wrote a script from
do you ever read the graphic novel
freaks of the heartland
he's another film school buddy of mine
and we just got along great and we did
this adaptation of this steve niles
graphic novel so cool a few years ago
and just had a great time so brought him
on board to to jump start exorcists with
me it's very cool
you